metaverse what an interesting word a
word that has been making quite some
noise for a few months now and will
probably impact us for years to come
metaversa as a term was first coined in
the 1992 science fiction novel
snowcrafts by neil stevenson as a
portmanteau of meta and universe meta is
a greek word that means after and is
used in the english language in
different ways it could denote a change
in condition like metamorphosis it could
denote something of a higher or second
order kind like metal language or in
colloquial english meta has become an
adjective which essentially means
extremely self-aware
self-reflective or self-referential as
in the phrase that's so meta in the case
of the metaverse the word is used quite
liberally and it means a virtual
universe a world where people are
connected to a virtual reality and
interact with each other the idea of a
virtual world has always been an
alluring topic for sci-fi writers most
of them consider it a dystopian reality
and neil stevenson goes as far as to
call the people constantly connected to
the metaverse gargoyles due to their
grotesque appearance today the metaverse
attempts to enter the vernacular and
disrupt our realities in a more subtle
way facebook has announced that it will
invest heavily in the metaverse more
specifically it will create software and
hardware that will allow humans to have
a fully immersive virtual or augmented
reality experience also in the crypto
sphere many companies have invested in
the idea of a metaverse by creating
virtual worlds where you can buy virtual
land or compete in virtual games so what
should our reaction be to all this is
the metaverse going to be a virtual
paradise or lay the groundwork for a
future dystopia
in the metaverse everybody has an avatar
a simulacrum of the real you we are
essentially trying to map the real world
onto a virtual reality the basic premise
of the metaverse is that it can offer an
alternative reality where some
limitations of the real world can be
transcended imagine a seems-like world
that is way more advanced and
sophisticated the idea started because
we tend to become more interconnected
than global and we need technologies
that can eliminate whatever limits our
connections in the metaverse we can
interact with people we want to know we
can discover worlds that exist in our
fantasies and compete or cooperate in
ways that are more immersive and
interesting the workplace can be a
virtual or augmented reality inside
one's apartment and the way people
collaborate can be as good as in the
real world sometimes even better in the
crypto world metaverse projects can
create new digital worlds where people
can exchange tokens
buy virtual land create their own
virtual kingdoms and probably come up
with innovative solutions when it comes
to government and coexistence all in all
the metaverse aims to become the
instigator for the creation of new
worlds inside our real world that will
automatically offer new opportunities to
people around the globe a benevolent
plan but is it really that way
i have said before that dystopias exist
everywhere and nowhere they are fed by
our demons and are projected outward as
physical creations that reflect the
color of our inner world by 2030
depression will be the number one cause
of illness worldwide dystopias are
essentially a manifestation of our
depression we can't really escape a
dystopian future for dystopias are
already here in many places around the
world dystopias are created due to lack
of planning corruption and false
prioritization people get carried away
due to social pressure and create
mediocre solutions that gravitate
towards more quantity and not more
quality i guess the virtual world
symbolizes our inability to make the
best out of our current world that's an
idea that i believe i can hear
percolating in the minds of many of my
viewers we need escapes and the
metaverse can be such an escape in the
metaverse the world won't be more real
but it can be what we want it to be
without us working really hard to make
it so it is a very alluring narrative
but with a crucial caveat in the
metaverse the world will be a simulation
with the companies who own this
simulation controlling everything you
see and experience there is some room
for virtual free will so to speak but
the world will be designed in a way that
will focus mainly on maximizing profit
for their respective companies
additionally because the metaverse will
be designed to feel addictive people
will lose touch with reality we are
already absorbed by fantasies
inside our phones and our computers
imagine what can happen if the space
that nurtures these fantasies
becomes even more immersive and isolated
our ability to physically connect will
eventually diminish
the real world will feel more and more
hostile and our mental issues will
become an actual pandemic the thing is
that with most technologies our ability
to partake in the decision making over
their adoption
is out of our hands and i'm not sure how
the companies that want to put forth
such technologies can maintain a certain
degree of responsibility towards their
users american technology ethicist
tristan harris puts it very nicely so
the real problem of humanity
is that we have paleolithic emotions
medieval institutions
and god-like technology
as said by e.o wilson the father of
sociobiology and the problem is that
these three operate on three different
clock rates what happens when your
god-like
is accelerating faster than your
steering wheel which is your medieval
institutions
and your paleolithic emotions your
ape-like instincts are guiding the whole
thing
so when i was a kid i was a magician and
magic is all about studying the limits
of our paleolithic emotions and while we
were all looking out for the moment when
technology would overwhelm human
strength that's when it takes our jobs
that's when it's smarter than us we miss
the much earlier point when technology
actually undermines human weaknesses and
this is the point that i would argue all
the things we're experiencing are going
wrong with technology because when
technology hacked our cognitive limits
our mental limits we feel that as
information overload
when it hacked our dopamine system we
feel that as addictive use when it hacks
our social validation we feel that as
mass narcissism everyone has to be an
instagram celebrity
when it hacks our confirmation bias we
feel that as fake news that we want to
it feels good to get information that
already confirms our beliefs and when it
hacks our outrage we feel that as
polarization and when it hacks our trust
the foundations of what we know to trust
or be true we feel that is deep fakes or
post-truth
and when you look at what this set of
things causes information overload leads
to shortening attention spans social
isolation teen depression suicide
breakdown of sense making conspiracy
theories and a post-truth world and
these are not disconnected problems
because they live in a connected system
of mutually reinforcing harm
and we call this system human
downgrading we have to fix it
i personally think that the timing for
the metaverse is not right i read in a
blog post that with this sort of change
its arc is as long and unpredictable as
its end state is lucrative i understand
that facebook wanted to capitalize on
the fact that people are used to work
and live from home due to our current
predicament but the mechanics of our
mental apparatus are not ready to allow
us to get fully immersed in virtual
reality sure some people might like it
and vr is a fun toy for some but our
brain's natural state has many
limitations it's easy to get addicted to
stimulation generated by technology but
we know that this is just a transient
feeling we already have good
technologies in place that allow us to
interact with each other i don't really
think that metaverse is solving a
problem and that opposes basic
entrepreneurship principles that suggest
that companies need to actually solve
problems unless we decide to create a
problem i can't really predict how the
future will look like i see the world
changing and evolving and i want to stay
optimistic the exposure to information
makes people smarter and more capable
but the complexity of our systems seems
so insurmountable that constantly
creates problems that each generation
needs to face i have said before that we
need to slow down slowing down allows us
to reflect deeply on our contemporary
issues and solve them in a more
effective way at the moment countries
and companies are part of a
technological arms race that keeps
nourishing our obsession with growth and
profits we focus more on feeding our
collective neurosis and we rarely
introspect instead of having a fruitful
philosophical dialogue about the future
of humanity and what constitutes
sustainability and prosperity we
aimlessly produce and consume this
dialogue will inevitably happen at some
point
hopefully it won't be too late
hey guys hope you enjoyed today's video
if you did make sure to like subscribe
turn on notifications
and comment below something cool please
so that more people can discover it
if you want to watch more videos from my
channel check out this one and this one
take care see you soon adrian out
you